y restaurar el lugar que le corresponde
a eeuu en el mundo esa es la meta de joe
biden una vez que asuma la presidencia
el exvicepresidente prometió
comprometerse otra vez con los aliados y
abandonar la política de donald trump de
américa first
by the prometió volver a unirse al
acuerdo climático de parís en su primer
día de trabajo en un artículo de opinión
en septiembre dijo que eeuu volvería al
pacto nuclear con irán siempre que se
cumpla los poderes europeos mientras
tanto han intentado salvar el acuerdo
pero el presidente electo enfrentará una
serie de desafíos desde teherán y una
falta de tiempo la confianza en eeuu se
ha erosionado y las elecciones
presidenciales en irán se avecinan
by then también buscaría terminar la
disputa comercial con la unión europea
pero su administración apuntará a
rectificar los desequilibrios
durante la campaña enfatizó como la
guerra comercial del trompo con china ha
herido a los campesinos estadounidenses
aunque es probable que mantenga una
postura dura con beijing
en el frente doméstico planea dar marcha
atrás a los recortes de impuestos de
trump e implementar una tasa impositiva
corporativa del 28% joe biden necesitará
reparar el daño que 'el hobbit' 19
ocasionó a la economía del país pero
primero deberá contener la pandemia
by then prometió escuchar a los
científicos y utilizará el periodo de
transición para reunirse con
gobernadores e imponer el uso
obligatorio de mascarillas a nivel
nacional el demócrata también buscará
expandir la histórica ley de salud
introducida durante su tiempo como
vicepresidente al brindar cobertura para
todos sin embargo la corte suprema debe
atender un caso que podría resultar en
la pérdida del seguro para 20 millones
de estadounidenses cuando su mal cargo
tendrá que lidiar con los efectos de
cualquier decisión final
hayden también prometió atacar la
violencia armada en eeuu planea hacerlo
mediante la prohibición de la
fabricación y venta de armas de asalto y
poniendo fin al almacenamiento bailén
que era una ley universal para la
verificación de antecedentes y terminar
con la venta en línea de armas de fuego